hi my name's Matthew parens I'm part of
the IBM cloud team and today I'm going
to give you an introduction to Tecton so
what is Tecton tech tongs started life
as part of the Kane 80 project as they
were trying to solve specific problems
around how they do continuous
integration and continuous delivery of
their software components and was later
dinner donated to the continuous
delivery foundation where we're now
being able to use it and consume it
across multiple cubanía environments and
platforms so what I want to do today is
give you an overview of the base
concepts that underpin what Tecton is on
explain about how you run it inside a
cube iniki's environment and how it
helps you automate and deliver your
software components for running inside
that platform and then I want to give a
brief explanation of how developers
would consume it and work with it and
how that separation of concerns may goes
forward so base level component of a
Tecton continuous integration or
delivery pipeline is something called a
task and a task is an automation tab
yeah an automation tasks that you need
to create that will help you build test
deploy manage check the health of a
particular piece of software once you
create a number of tasks you can
actually isolate them and reuse them
very easily and Tecton one of the real
benefits is that it allows you to
separate your tasks that are then
consumed by your developers and I'll
explain that in a little bit more detail
as we move forward so once you've got a
base element task you can create
something called a pipeline and a
pipeline
can be made up about any number of tasks
so you can customize that and tailor it
for the specific software needs that you
have once you've defined a pipeline you
can trigger a pipeline from something
called a pipeline run and you create
multiple runs in a software delivery
project but it will continue to run the
exact same definition of the pipeline
that you defined with the exact same
definition of the task that you define
now one of the next pieces of key
information to make this sequence run
smoothly is you need to provide some
data for that execution so that you can
tailor and customize it anything from a
build number to supplying a unique git
repository or supplying a docker image
and this is called
pipeline resource res so now we built
these base components for a Tecton
pipeline what we need to do is then
start to think about how we prepare a
developer to consume them so what were
you dippity-do is you'd register your
common tasks into your Cuba needs
environment inside the Tecton execution
engine that you will install inside Cuba
natives and those tasks can be commonly
shared across different applications or
different development teams so it allows
a level of Management and control that
can be owned by the operation the
operations side of your DevOps
organization so Tecton itself runs
inside the Cuban es cluster and it
associates very cleanly to a lot of the
Cuban ease concepts like pods and
services and CR CRC llamo definitions so
once you've got your pipelines defined
or the concepts about how you're going
to use your pipelines and once you've
actually installed and got Tecton
running inside your Cuban YZ environment
what we need to do is then talk about
how I do
would start using that in the creation
and delivery of their projects so as I
mentioned you can have different Tecton
pipeline definitions and we'll call that
pipe line yama and you can define that
file inside your individual application
and the relationship if you remember is
a pipeline can run any number of tasks
and these tasks have been already
registered and defined inside the Tecton
environment so you can have task 1 task
to task 3 and keep going
and within each task you can have a
number of steps and again you can have
any number of steps depending on the
particular problem you're trying to
solve
so once you've defined your pipeline
definition inside your application then
the developer can push their change to
their git repository and this will allow
them to iterate multiple times on code
changes or definition changes or feature
and function improvements and what
happens is this triggers a webhook which
will then trigger a type a Tecton
execution which will then marry the two
elements together it will marry their
pipeline definition that comes from the
application and it will take the tasks
that you've defined inside your Tecton
environment and this could result and we
hope it does successful delivery of your
applications into specific namespaces
whether it be a dev a test or a pre prod
so you've actually packaged up your code
into a k8 a k8 image registry and from
there you've now got a piece of packaged
software that you can then roll out and
deploy to other environments so I hope
you you enjoyed that walkthrough and
you've got some information about the
basic concepts of what
is how applications can use in and how
you run it on top of the Cuban ease
platform thank you if you have any
questions please drop us a line below if
you want to see more videos like this in
the future please like and subscribe and
don't forget you can always get started
on the cloud at no cost by signing up
for a free I be M cloud account